[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
سنبدا هجومنا خلال ساعات او ايام قليله
تنتشي بهجومها المضاد والروس يشمرون عن
سواعدهم ويعدون العده خدعه امريكيه في
الاسلحه المقدمه لاوكرانيا وقوتك تخترق
الاراضي الروسيه مجددا فكيف سيرد الكرملين
هذه المره واستراتيجيه روسيه جديده لحسم
الحرب وصافره الانذار الاوكرانيه تصرخ مع
اعلان قوتك حاله التاهب القصوى وبعد اعلان
الطباخ بوتين الانسحاب فجاه من بغموت الرد
ياتي من قدروف بالسودان تتواصل الاشتباكات
والسعوديه تعلن بدء الحوار السوداني على
اراضيها فهل تنهي الرياض حرب الخرطوم
بينما واشنطن تحضر مئه زورق حربي لمواجهه
طهران وبريطانيا تنصب تشارلز ملكا في اكبر
احتفال منذ سبعين عاما هيران واسرائيل
تتوددان للسعوديه فمن سيظفر بود المملكه
اذا الوضع وصل لمرحله الخطر العراق يستنجد
بالمجتمع الدولي
موسكو تحدث استراتيجيه الهجوم
تشمر عن ساعدها وموسكوا تغير استراتيجيته
لتدخل الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه مرحله
صعبه لا رجعه منها وها هي السلطات
المواليه لروسيا تعلن انها تتوقع بدا
الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد خلال ايام او حتى
ساعات ليعلن القائم باعمال حاكم مقاطعه
[موسيقى]
عشره منطقه سكنيه وبلده بعيدا عن منازلهم
والسبب هو تكليف القوات الاوكرانيه القصف
عليها حسب قوله وفق وكاله تاز من جانبها
روسيا كانت
[موسيقى]
الانسحاب من بخموت في العاشر من الشهر
الجاري ليعلن تسليم مواقعه لقوات الرئيس
الشيشاني رمضان قديروف يتكفل الاخير
بمواصله القتال وتحقيق النجاح اليكم
المصدر
لقد كتبت رساله الى القائد الاعلى للقوات
المسلحه مفادها اننا مستعدون لتولي
مسؤوليه ضخم وسنكون سعداء للغايه
بالاستيلاء على الاراضي المتبقيه هناك
لدينا الموارد والوسائل لاستبدال اي شخص
لا يستطيع التعامل معها والجنود في حاله
التاهب نحن في انتظار الامر لقد تحركت عده
وحدات نحو مناطق العمليه العسكريه
فهل يستطيع قادروف تحقيق نقله نوعيه في
هجمات القوات الروسيه كما هو معروف عنه
لتاتي الاجابه من العاصمه الاوكرانيه
والتي اعتبرت تهديد القائد بالانسحاب من
بخموت خدعه لاكمال السيطره على المدينه
بالتزامن مع الاحتفال بيوم النصر امام
يخدع من لينتقل الاوكران من الدفاع الى
الهجوم وباستخدام سلاح الاوكراني تم اسقاط
مسيره تابعه له فوق وذلك بعدما فقد
السيطره عليها وكانه يلطم خديه بيديه ولكن
ليست كل الهجمات الاوكرانيه فاشله حيث
تعرضت منشاه النفطيه جنوبي روسيا لهجوم
ثاني بالمسيرات في غضون اربع وعشرين ساعه
لتفيد سلطات الطوارئ الروسيه فكره عن
اندلاع حريق في منشاه السكين فهل من رد
روسي قريب ومن حرب المسيرات الى معارك
اسقاط الصواريخ فقوه اوكرانيا تقول انها
اسقطت للمره الاولى صاروخ كينجال الروسي
الذي تفوق سرعته سرعه الصوت وذلك باستخدام
نظام الامريكي مهلا مهلا مهلا هل هي حقيقه
للعلم امريكا بنفسها اعترفت انها لا
تستطيع صده فكيف صده الاوكران الي
بعد ان وصفها الرئيس الروسي في وقت سابق
بالسلاح المثالي اعلنت القوات الاوكرانيه
نجاحا نظام الدفاع الجوي باتريوت باسقاط
الصاروخ الروسي تفوق سرعته سرعه الصوت هنا
مستشار رئيس جمهوريه القرم الروسيه يقول
بانه مسقطوا صاروخين البالستيين اوكرانيين
فوق شبه الجزيره وبين كل تلك الهجمات
تواجه اوكرانيا مازقا عسكريا قبل الهجوم
المضاد حيث ذكرت صحيفه بوستر الامريكيه ان
واشنطن تبحث دعم الدفاعات الجويه
الاوكرانيه بمزيد من الصواريخ لصد الهجمات
الروسيه خاصه سلاح الطيران وتاتي المساعي
الامريكيه مع قرب نفاذ مخزون كييف من
الصواريخ بسبب تصديها للغارات الروسيه
فماذا لو نفذت تلك الصواريخ وللعلم ستفقد
اوكرانيا هذه المساعدات الخارجيه اذا فشلت
في تحقيق توقعات الولايات المتحده خلال
الحرب ضد روسيا خصوصا في الهجوم المضاد
لسنا نحن من صرح بل صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
اما الولايات المتحده فجعلت الامر يشتبه
علينا فمن جهه تدعمك ومن جهه لا ترغب
بتحقيق انتصار اوكراني حيث كتبت صحيفه
بولس عن مسؤولين امريكيين قولهم ان
البنتاغون تعديلات سريه على منظومه
بعيده المدى ومن واشنطن ننتقل الى المانيا
حيث يتم تنفيذ تدريبات لجنود الاوكرانيين
على دبابه ليوبار في ساحه تدريب عسكريه في
كليدز شرق المانيا جنبا الى جنب هولندا
ودنمارك وندف تمكين الجنود الاوكرانيين من
تشغيلها وصيانتها بشكل فعال وحتى الان تم
تدريب اكثر من ثلاثه الاف جندي اوكراني في
ارض التدريب بكليدز المتوقع ان يصل هذا
العدد الى تسعه الاف بحلول نهايه العام
ومن الحرب الاوكرانيه الى الازمه
الاوروبيه وبعد اهانه رئيسه الحكومه
الايطاليه من قبل وزير الداخليه الفرنسيه
الى حوار هادئ مع روما بشان ملف الهجره
بصيص امل سوداني
المعارك لا تنتهي والسودان يدخل في نفق
مظلم فهل الى حوار من سبيل وفي برقه امل
جديده طرف النزاع في السودان اعلنان عن
انطلاق المحادثات في جده بالسعوديه وبرغم
هذه المحادثات فان الاشتباكات لم تتوقف
على الميدان حيث شن الجيش غارات عده على
مواقع لقوات الدعم السريع في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم وقالت مصادر سودانيه ان
مناوشات عده اندلعت وسط الخرطوم وسط تبادل
للاتهامات بخرق الهدنه الجاريه ومع
استمرار الهجمات من الطرفين انقطع الماء
والكهرباء عن مناطق واسعه بالبلاد ليعيش
السودانيون في عطش وظلام
دامساوه هذه الحربيه ساده لتستغل واشنطن
هذه الاوضاع في السودان ويصدر الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن امرا بتحضير قائمه
عقوبات لعده اشخاص ومن بينهم طرف النزاع
بالسوداء
الاحداث والتطورات
افادت وكاله بان الولايات المتحده تخطط
لارسال اسلحه بقيمه 500 مليون دولار الى
تايوان وفقا لنفس المخطط العاجل المستخدم
لمساعده اوكرانيا عسكريا الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تخطط لنشر مئه زورق مسير اضافي
في بحر الخليج للقيام بدوريات في مواجهات
ايران بحسب ايضا شهدت بريطانيا تتويجه
تشارز الثالث ملكا للبلاد في اكبر احتفال
رسمي تشهده البلاد منذ 70 عاما في عرض
يتسم بالعظمه والفخامه لمهرجان يعود
تاريخه الى الف عام صرح مستشار الامن
القومي الاسرائيلي بان بلاده تامل نجاح
محاولاتها لتطبيع العلاقات مع السعوديه
خلال زياره مستشار الامن القومي للبيت
الابيض
للمملكه هذا الاسبوع وفق سبوتنيك الرئيس
الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي ايران والسعوديه
دولتان كبيرتان وعوده العلاقات بينهما
ستغير المعادلات في المنطقه
وتنظمها الشعوب المسلمه في المنطقه تتجه
نحو دعم المقاومه ودعم العداله لا نقبل ان
تعد السعوديه عدوا لنا شدد رئيس الوزراء
العراقي محمد شياع السوداني على انخفاض
مناسيب مياه نهري دجله والفرات استدعي
تدخل دوليا عاجلا مضيفا نحتاج فيه الى
جهود جميع الاصدقاء لمساعده العراق في
ضمان امنه المائي ومستقبل اجياله مع
اقتراب الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد لا شيء
يلوح في الافق بقرب تحقيق نصر اوكراني ومع
تغيير روسيا الاستراتيجيه هجومها لا زالت
الاوضاع في اوكرانيا على حالها فه ل يميل
الطرفان الى الحوار
[موسيقى]